* Schwere Atemzüge *
* Jubelrufe *
Was ist jetzt der Plan?
Äh, zelten!
- Wo?
Ist das schon geplant?
- Wahrscheinlich dort hinten.
Da oben?
- Ja.
Wir haben einen Spion
auf der Tadschikistan-Seite.
Wir wollten doch immer schon
nach Tadschikistan.
Jetzt sind wir da.
- Wir sind da.
Wir haben sie verarscht.
Wir haben den Fünfer und das Weggli.
Eigentlich
bräuchten wir ein Visum, nicht?
* Die anderen lachen. *
Keinen Schritt weiter!
Super gemacht.
Ich gratuliere.
* Russische Durchsage *
Warte!
In der blitzblanken Abflughalle
des Moskauer Flughafens
Scheremetjewo.
Das SAC-Expeditionsteam wartet auf
den Weiterflug nach Kirgistan.
* Verträumte Klaviermusik *
Um Mitternacht landet die Aeroflot-
Maschine in Osh im Süden Kirgistans.
Das Team
wird von Zhunnusbek empfangen,
dem Leiter
einer lokalen Expeditionsagentur.
There's only five minutes
to go to the hotel, okay.
(Frauen) Okay.
* Feierliche Akkordeonmusik
aus dem Radio *
Zwei Nächte wird das Expeditionsteam
in Osh verbringen,
bevor es zum Pamirgebirge im
Grenzgebiet zu Tadschikistan reist.
Mit ihren knapp 300'000 Einwohnern
ist Osh
die zweitgrösste Stadt des Landes.
An der ehemaligen Seidenstrasse
gelegen,
ist sie seit rund 3'000 Jahren
ein wichtiges Zentrum für den Handel.
* Orientalisch wirkende Musik *
Try this.
1 kg.
- 1 kg?
1 kg ...
60.
* Der Verkäufer spricht russisch. *
Das Team fährt rund 350 km
in westlicher Richtung
entlang der Turkestankette,
einem Ausläufer des Pamirgebirges.
Kirgistan ist fast fünfmal so gross
wie die Schweiz,
hat aber nur gut 6 Mio. Einwohner.
Gerade der südwestliche Zipfel des
Landes ist extrem spärlich besiedelt.
* Antreibende Musik *
* Hupen *
Gegen Mittag entdeckt das Team
eine Bäckerei an der Überlandstrasse.
Das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Mehr, was?
(Mann) Okay.
(Mann) No, no, no, no.
* Er spricht russisch. *
No, I want you to take it.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
* Antreibende Musik *
Das gibt sicher ein gutes Bild.
Nach 8 Std. Fahrt
erreichen sie Sari-Jaz,
den Ausgangspunkt der Expedition
auf 2'600 m ü.M.
Es ist einfach wunderbar.
Unglaublich.
Wir sind hier völlig abgelegen,
allein auf der Welt.
Ja, das ist wirklich
eine magische Erfahrung.
Und die Girls sind hoch motiviert,
sie lachen andauernd.
Ich denke,
das wird eine grossartige Erfahrung.
Drink wine!
- Drink wine, yes.
Yeah, drink.
Kurz nach Tagesanbruch.
Die kirgisischen Guides
und Eseltreiber warten,
bis das Expeditionsteam
zum Aufbruch bereit ist.
In zwei Tagesmärschen
wollen die Alpinistinnen
das Min-Teke-Tal erreichen,
das Tal der 1'000 Steinböcke.
Dort werden sie auf 3'100 m
ihr base camp einrichten.
Wir packen die Taschen für heute,
bevor die Tiere beladen werden.
Alle Schlafsäcke
kommen in eine Tasche,
und wir nehmen nur
einen Tagesrucksack mit uns.
Irgendwie cool mit den Eseln,
aber andererseits
haben wir so viel Zeug dabei,
dass wir es nicht selbst
tragen können. Das ist auch seltsam.
Fünf kirgisische Guides
transportieren
die 500 kg Material des Teams
auf 30 Eseln und Pferden
durch das Gebirge.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Seid vorsichtig, okay?
Folgt immer den Guides.
- Ja.
* Sphärische Klänge *
Man sieht die Berge schon.
Halb aus den Wolken raus.
* Sie jubeln leise. *
Megaschön.
(Andere Frau)
Fast wie das Matterhorn.
* Antreibende Musik *
Drei Bergketten,
4'200 Höhenmeter und 80 km
liegen zwischen ihnen
und dem base camp.
Die Gegend ist menschenleer.
Nur vereinzelt
treffen sie auf Hirten,
die ihre Tiere
auf den kargen Hügeln weiden lassen.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
(Lachend) Er sagt, es sei kalt.
* Die Frauen lachen. *
Biberli Switzarski.
Ah. Spasiba.
Ah, n... Oh.
(Lachend) Spasiba.
- Spasiba.
* Er spricht weiter russisch. *
Wow, cool.
Kerne?
- Nein, Aprikosen.
Wie sagt man noch gleich ...
- Spasiba?
Rachmat.
- Rachmat. Spasiba.
Sie sehen nicht so gut aus -
in meinem war noch ein Stein,
wohl, weil er
ihn so in der Tasche hatte -,
aber sie sind megalecker.
* Der Hirte spricht russisch. *
(Mann) Spasiba.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
(Alle) Auf Wiedersehen.
* Fliessende, idyllische Musik *
* Kurzer Pfiff *
Am späten Nachmittag
haben die Expeditionsteilnehmerinnen
bereits einen grossen Abstand
zu den Lasttieren und ihren Treibern.
Les donkeys ...
On n'est même plus avec les donkeys.
Wo sind sie denn?
Etwa baden gegangen?
Wir haben irgendwann
unsere Esel überholt,
die unsere Biwak-Sachen dabei haben.
Und es wird bald ...
Die Sonne geht bald unter,
und es wird ohne Biwak recht kalt.
Wir wissen nicht, wo die Esel
mit den Biwak-Sachen sind.
Und, ja, darum rufe ich mal
unseren Tourguide an und frage ...
Es läuft darauf hinaus, dass wir
entweder wieder absteigen müssen,
wo wir hergekommen sind,
oder wir ziehen es durch,
steigen noch auf diesen Berg
und hoffen,
dass die andere Gruppe da oben ist.
(Computerstimme)
... account information.
Please wait
while your call is connected.
+99...
Hello, Zhunnusbek?
Ja, geil,
wir haben den Empfang verloren.
* Sphärischer Klang *
Mir ist es egal,
ich kann die ganze Nacht laufen.
Ja, aber wenn wir hinuntergehen
und sie nicht da sind,
haben wir keine Schlafsäcke.
Aber oben ist es viel kälter
und es gibt kaum Wasser.
Was, wenn sie nicht oben sind
und wir gehen
ins andere Tal hinunter
und dort sind sie auch nicht?
Abstimmen?
Wenn wir weitergehen,
müssen alle einverstanden sein.
Ich glaube, beides ist falsch.
Für mich
gibt es einfach viele Warnsignale,
da hochzugehen -
an einen Ort, den wir nicht kennen.
Die Diskussion zieht sich endlos hin.
Aber manchmal
löst sich ein Problem von selbst,
wenn man nur
lange genug darüber redet.
Da kommen Leute.
Ah ja, des ...
- Donkeys?
Or something.
- There's something.
Yes, donkeys.
- Okay, noch mehr Esel kommen.
Sie waren einfach langsam
und wir haben gehetzt.
Ah, okay, okay. Okay.
(Silvan) Mirjam, ich glaube,
du musst losgehen.
Are we on the right path?
Sind wir auf dem richtigen Weg?
* Er spricht russisch. *
Wir sind jetzt ca. auf 2'300 m,
und die Basis ist auf 3'300.
Wir sind
in der Hälfte des Aufstiegs.
Offenbar schlafen wir hier.
Die Esel gehen weiter -
ich weiss nicht genau, wie weit.
Die Kommunikation ist schwierig.
Aber hier gibt's Wasser
und da ist da ist das Hüttchen.
Inwendig. Inwendig oder vorne.
Man geht immer so lange hoch
und sieht nur den Boden -
also keine richtigen Berge.
Und dann ist man plötzlich hier oben
und hat den Überblick.
Du gehst den Pass hoch
und hast keine Ahnung,
was du zu Gesicht bekommen wirst,
weil du nur
20- bis 30-jährige Karten
und Schwarz-Weiss-Fotos kennst.
Wir sind auf einer Entdeckungsreise.
Unglaublich!
* Ruhige, langsame Klänge *
Devant c'est la neige.
- C'est pas encore sûr.
Wir haben den meisten Bergen ...
Das ist das Breithorn,
da hinten das Klein Matterhorn,
dort sind Lenzspitze und Nadelhorn
mit der Wand.
Ja, es ist relativ klar,
wer wovon spricht,
wenn wir Schweizer Bergnamen
für ähnliche Formen übernehmen.
* Langsame, sphärische Klänge *
Wir werden erst morgen
im base camp ankommen.
Die Esel gehen schon weiter.
Die Pferde sind langsamer,
weil das Gelände hier
schwierig für sie ist.
Wir müssen bei den Pferden bleiben.
Sie tragen unser ganzes Gepäck
fürs Campieren.
Wir sind
einen anderen Rhythmus gewohnt.
Bei uns heisst es:
"Geh, renn, halte den Zeitplan ein!"
Die Guides sagten uns heute morgen,
um 7 Uhr gebe es Frühstück.
Also waren wir punkt 7 Uhr bereit.
Sie meinten natürlich
7 Uhr nach kirgisischer Zeit,
nicht nach Schweizer Zeit.
Wir hatten noch viel Zeit,
unser Zeug zu packen.
Das Leben von Florence in der Schweiz
ist geprägt von Zuverlässigkeit,
Pünktlichkeit und Struktur.
Florence steht im letzten Jahr
ihres Medizinstudiums.
Florence ist extrem motiviert
und extrem fokussiert.
Wahrscheinlich macht sie im Leben
alles mit dieser Intensität.
Es ist eine Freude,
solche Menschen zu sehen,
in der Ausbildung zu begleiten
und zu wissen, dass sie ihren Weg
in der Medizin machen werden.
Dann sehen Sie's. Die Kennzahl ...
Es ist schon schwierig,
die ganze Zeit drin zu sitzen
und die Berge vor der Nase zu haben.
Man kriegt richtig Lust. Und jetzt
ist auch noch der Schnee gekommen.
Jeden Morgen schaue ich hoch, um zu
sehen, wie die Verhältnisse sind.
Hoffentlich
wird's am Wochenende schön.
Die Angst,
dass man das ganze Leben lang
eine Work-Life-Balance haben muss.
Ich glaube,
man darf auch Prioritäten setzen.
Es ist eine Illusion,
überall gut sein zu wollen.
Da verzettelt man sich.
Man muss auch den Mut haben,
eine Wahl zu treffen.
Aber das Gute daran ist,
dass sie in der jetzigen Situation
viel lernen wird,
was auch für ihren Beruf
wichtig ist.
Im kirgisischen Jiptiktal
kümmern sich die Tiertreiber vor dem
Eindunkeln um das Wohl der Tiere.
Währenddessen versammelt sich die
Truppe zur abendlichen Besprechung.
Ihr habt diesen Trip organisiert,
und jetzt ist er Realität.
Ihr habt uns alle
hier zusammengebracht.
Das ist unglaublich stark.
Sich etwas vorzustellen
und es dann zu kreieren ―
das ist wirklich speziell.
Je mehr Wahlmöglichkeiten
wir im Leben haben,
umso schwieriger wird es.
Das Härteste im Leben ist,
eine Entscheidung zu treffen.
Welche Schule soll ich besuchen,
in welches Restaurant gehen?
Man hat immer das Gefühl,
den Kürzeren zu ziehen.
Merkt euch:
Alles, was wir tun, ist ein Erfolg,
auch wenn ihr nicht
die steilste Wand,
die schwierigste Route,
den höchsten Gipfel schafft.
Bringt die Dinge
in die richtige Perspektive,
dann seid ihr
am Ende des Tages zufrieden.
Das Expeditionsteam
nimmt den letzten Abschnitt des Weges
zum base camp in Angriff.
Noch einen Pass
gilt es zu überwinden.
* Helle, verträumte Musik *
Base camp!
Irgendjemand macht Feuer.
Ich glaube, es ist einer der Guides.
Er nimmt gerade
den Teekocher vom Feuer.
* Lachen *
Ohne Scheiss.
Ach, du siehst das auch so, was?
- Komm, wir gehen.
Mit der Kamera sehe ich,
dass es ein Teekocher ist.
Auch Lydiane hat es geschafft.
Seit der Abreise von Osh
schlägt sie sich
mit einer Magenverstimmung herum.
Ich vermute, es geht ein Virus um.
Wir sind alle
relativ nahe aufeinander,
schlafen im selben Zelt
und haben nicht so viele Ressourcen
wie zu Hause.
Deshalb haben wir alle
Anfangsschwierigkeiten.
Aber das wird vorbeigehen.
* Er jubelt. *
Hey, Ali!
- Good.
Good job, Ali. Thank you.
Zum Wohl.
- Zum Wohl, Lisa.
Zum Wohl, Lydiane. Bravo, bravo.
Bravo. Danke.
Ramona, bravo. Zum Wohl.
Baimurza,
einer der kirgisischen Guides,
sammelt
vertrocknete Wachholderzweige.
* Mysteriöse Musik *
Das Räucherwerk dient dem Schutz
und der Reinigung
und ist Teil
des uralten Schamanenwissens,
das hier immer noch lebendig ist.
Smells good.
Es raucht direkt über mein Essen.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
Und vielleicht hilft es auch,
die kirgisischen Berggeister
milde zu stimmen
für die Unternehmungen der Schweize-
rinnen in den nächsten Wochen.
* Langsame Gitarrenmelodie *
Trotz Müdigkeit und Magenproblemen
erkundet das Team
gemeinsam die Gegend.
Sie wollen ein genaueres Bild
von den Herausforderungen bekommen,
denen sie sich stellen werden.
Mit dem ungenauen
und veralteten Kartenmaterial
war es
von der Schweiz aus nicht möglich,
alles bis ins Detail zu planen.
* Langsame Gitarrenmelodie *
Drei Ruhetage
hat sich das Team gegönnt.
Jetzt machen sich
die Bergsteigerinnen auf
zu einer Akklimatisationstour
auf einen über 5'000 m hohen Berg.
Ein erster Test
für die jungen Frauen,
wie sie mit dieser Höhe klarkommen.
Gerade Lisa, die seit einigen Jahren
an Leistungsasthma leidet,
ist positiv überrascht.
Gerade läuft alles
besser als erwartet.
Erstens müssen wir hier nicht mühsam
klettern, sondern können laufen,
zweitens bin ich fit wie ein
Turnschuh und weiss nicht, wieso.
Normalerweise
bin ich hinten im Team und keuche,
und die anderen fragen, ob sie was
aus meinem Rucksack nehmen sollen.
Jetzt läuft es einfach.
Das ist cool.
Es ist in dieser Gruppe
fast ungewohnt, aber es ist cool.
Lisa
studiert Maschinenbau an der ZHAW.
Lisa ist unsere älteste Tochter.
Wir haben noch drei Jungs.
Weil ich nur  e i n  Mädchen habe,
hätte ich ihr gerne
jeweils die Haare geflochten,
aber das mochte sie gar nicht.
Sie trug auch nie einen Rock.
Sie trug lange nur Latzhosen.
Sie sagte, sie brauche Latzhosen,
weil die viel praktischer seien,
wenn man auf Bäume klettere.
Ich habe in der "20 Minuten"
gelesen, es gebe Tierschützer,
die sagen, man solle Katzen
nicht mehr rauslassen,
weil sie von einem Auto
überfahren werden könnten.
Das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Katzen gehören nach draussen
und Lisa gehört in die Berge.
* Langsame Gitarrenmusik *
Ich glaube,
zuunterst ist eine Pilzcremesuppe,
dann Stocki, dann getrocknete Pilze
und jetzt noch Käse.
Dann schmeckt es am Ende
auch nach etwas.
(Lachend) Schläfst du schon?
* Lachen *
Es ist megaschön.
- Mhm, jetzt ist es schön.
Krass, wo wir sind.
- In Kirgistan?
Das kommt mir nicht mehr
wie ein Fremdwort vor,
wir sprechen schon so lange davon.
Aber dass wir in Asien sind,
kommt mir komisch vor.
Die Berge haben keine Schlitzaugen.
Die sehen aus wie bei uns.
Breithorn, Klein Matterhorn ...
- ... Katzenhöhe ...
Der ist nicht bei uns.
- Bernina.
Nach der zweitägigen
Akklimatisationstour
sind Waschen
und Körperpflege angesagt.
Der Fluss vor dem Camp
entspringt dem Gletscher des Min Teke
und führt eiskalte Gletschermilch.
Ah, Scheisse!
Die kirgisischen Guides
sind inzwischen dabei,
den Vorrat aus frischem Brot
aufzustocken.
Ich will sieben Kinder.
Ich will drei.
Nein, sieben.
- Du brauchst mehr Frauen.
Du hast eins, ich mache drei,
du brauchst also noch drei mehr.
Ich, sieben Kinder?
Und Berge?
Keine Berge mehr für mich?
Berge? Nein.
Ja, doch, Berge!
- Ah, da bin ich glücklich.
Er hat schon ein Kind,
will aber sieben,
d.h., ich muss noch sechs machen.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Samir und Ali sind Brüder.
86 und 87.
Ali arbeitet schon am fünften Kind.
Samir hat eins.
Die anderen beiden
haben auch schon ...
Sie sind 91er - Iora und Waimurza.
Jorra.
- Giora. Iorra? Giorra.
Nein, Jorra.
- Jorra? Jorra.
Und Waimurza
hat auch schon ein Kind.
Sie wollen jetzt wissen,
ob wir verheiratet sind,
wie viele Kinder wir haben,
ob wir Männer zu Hause haben
oder wir auch kirgisische Männer
nehmen würden.
Vielleicht nur eins,
dann geht's besser.
Das Team
plant bereits die nächste Tour.
Die Kirgistan-Expedition
bildet den Abschluss
der dreijährigen Ausbildung.
Die jungen Alpinistinnen treffen ihre
Entscheidungen jetzt selbstständig.
Bergführerin Caro gibt dabei
lediglich ein mögliches Thema vor.
Euer nächstes Ziel
sollte die grösste Herausforderung
der Expedition sein.
Und dann ein kleineres Ziel wie z.B.
Pik Aschu gegen Ende des Trips.
Ich denke, der nächste Gipfel
sollte einer sein,
der euch alles abverlangt.
Do the bigger summit.
Eine Möglichkeit
wäre der Gipfel hinter Aschu.
Wir nennen ihn den Berg,
den wir vielleicht schaffen.
Clearly, yes.
Vielleicht
sollten wir morgen starten.
Für den Min Teke
benötigen wir rund vier Tage.
Das Wetter ist stabil,
die Temperaturen warm.
Könnte cool sein, das zu versuchen.
Es ist einfach so, dass die Wand mit
Eis und Schnee ziemlich steil ist.
Do you mean the first one?
- The first one.
Wir dachten, die könnten wir
am Nachmittag bewältigen,
weil dann die Eisqualität
vielleicht besser ist.
Die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten
werden in Erwägung gezogen.
Nach 1 Std. Diskussion
entscheidet sich das Team,
gemeinsam eine ambitionierte
Erstbesteigung in Angriff zu nehmen.
Morgen brechen wir zum Min Teke auf.
Am Ende des Gletschers werden wir
ein vorgeschobenes Camp aufschlagen,
am Anfang des Schneehangs.
Es geht los.
Lydiane ist seit ihren Teenagerjahren
auf der ganzen Welt unterwegs.
Lydiane hat
ein draufgängerisches Temperament.
Als sie klein war, handelte sie
immer, bevor sie nachdachte.
Mit dem Alter wurde das besser.
Ihre Reiserei hat viel
zu ihrem Charakter beigetragen.
Als sie
14 1/2 Jahre alt war,
reiste sie allein nach Madagaskar.
Das formte sie sehr.
Sie war auch in Asien,
in der Mongolei -
sie hat alles bereist.
Ich glaube, ein wichtiger Faktor
ist das Vertrauen der Eltern -
im Rahmen des Vernünftigen
jedenfalls.
Sie liebt, was sie tut, also werde
ich ihr auch weiterhin vertrauen.
* Vereinzelte sphärische Klänge *
Gedrückte Stimmung im base camp.
Lydiane und Silvan
plagen immer noch Magenprobleme.
Sie vermuten eine bakterielle
Verunreinigung des Essens,
das sie am ersten Tag in Osh
eingenommen haben.
Im Moment sind wir
ein bisschen auf Stand-by.
Einige der Mädchen fühlen sich krank
und haben schlecht geschlafen.
Sie haben v.a. Magenprobleme,
das ist ein konstantes Thema
auf dem ganzen Trip.
Jeder hat ständig Magenprobleme.
Wir werden sehen,
was sie entscheiden.
Wenn es
um die Entscheidungsfindung geht,
lasse ich sie das jeweils
unter sich besprechen.
So können sie frei kommunizieren,
und dann sehe ich,
was sie entschieden haben.
Die jungen Alpinistinnen
haben einen Entscheid gefällt.
Sie wollen den Min Teke
heute in Angriff nehmen.
Es muss einem einfach bewusst sein,
dass es gesundheitliche Probleme
geben könnte,
wenn man sich nicht fit fühlt.
Aber ich bin zuversichtlich,
weil es auf der ersten Etappe
auch Rückzugsmöglichkeiten gibt,
zumindest bis zum base camp.
So kann ich einfach mal schauen,
wie es mir den Tag über geht.
Silvan bleibt im Camp zurück. Er ist
zu schwach für die viertägige Tour.
Lydiane hingegen
will auf keinen Fall verzichten.
Geplant ist, am ersten Tag
den Einstieg zum Min Teke
hinter einem ausgedehnten
Gletscherbruch zu schaffen
und ein erstes Mal zu campen.
In zwei weiteren Tagesetappen will
das Team dann den Gipfel erreichen.
* Schwebende, sphärische Musik *
Ab jetzt tragen die Alpinistinnen
das Material selbst:
Ausrüstung und Nahrung für vier Tage.
Is that a lot?
Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
Die Rucksäcke sind über 20 kg schwer.
Das Team bricht auf
in unbekanntes Gelände
und muss für alle möglichen
Bedingungen ausgerüstet sein.
Vor dem Gletscher
müssen die Alpinistinnen entscheiden,
ob sie heute
über den ersten Abbruch aufsteigen
oder ob sie hier übernachten wollen.
Ist es nicht besser,
wenn wir uns das erst mal ansehen
und dann morgen wieder hochgehen?
Ich fürchte,
wir gefährden unseren Gipfeltag,
wenn wir hier die Nacht verbringen.
Der Tag morgen wird gigantisch.
Lasst uns in 10 Min. entscheiden, ob
wir mit oder ohne Gepäck hochgehen.
Caro lässt das Team allein beraten.
Am Schluss
ihrer dreijährigen Ausbildung
sind die jungen Frauen für solche
Entscheidungen selbst zuständig.
Wir haben eine Linie,
auf der wir vielleicht durchkommen.
Wir glauben, dass dort die wenigsten
objektiven Gefahren sind.
Wir haben gesagt,
wir gehen mal mit dem Rucksack los.
Das Ziel ist, wenn's gut geht,
dass wir hochkommen und oben auf dem
flachen Gletscher schlafen können.
Jetzt gehen wir bis
zum nächsten Entscheidungspunkt,
den wir uns gesetzt haben,
und wenn's nicht geht,
drehen wir um und schlafen hier.
Dann machen wir eine andere Tour.
Das Team macht sich auf den Weg,
um die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten
auszukundschaften.
* Grollen *
Auf der linken Seite des Gletschers
ist gerade
ein Sérac heruntergekommen.
Das war
eine unserer Aufstiegsoptionen.
Jetzt haben wir noch zwei übrig.
Der beste Weg scheint schliesslich
durch einen Gletscherbruch zu führen.
* Fluktuierende, sphärische Klänge *
* Langsame, getragene Musik *
Der Abbruch
birgt unsichtbare Gefahren.
Jeden Moment
können sich Eismassen verschieben.
Es ist eine verzauberte Welt,
durch die sie kommen.
Nach 1 Std. in der Eisschlucht
macht sich das Team an den Ausstieg.
Wenn sie die Ebene
hinter dem Abbruch erreichen,
haben sie
ihr erstes Tagesziel geschafft.
Lydiane, relais!
* Kurzer Pfiff *
C'est bon, Lydiane!
Das ist so cool.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass man
hier gleich auf der Höhe ist.
Ramona ist in Brig aufgewachsen
und studiert Sport-
und Bewegungswissenschaften.
Schon als Kind hat sie körperliche
Herausforderungen geliebt.
Ich kann mich erinnern,
als sie zwei- oder dreijährig war -
eher zweijährig - liess ich sie
am Bahnhof Brig
mal die Fassade hochklettern.
Ich schaute unten natürlich schon,
dass nichts passiert.
Die anderen Eltern hatten Panik,
weil ich das Kind 7 oder 8 m
an der Fassade hoch-
und wieder runterklettern liess.
Ein andermal waren wir
in der Alphütte, und es regnete.
Wir sassen drin und kochten
oder taten sonst etwas,
und plötzlich fragten wir uns,
wo Ramona war.
Wir konnten sie nicht finden.
Sie war über die Leiter aufs Dach
geklettert, im grössten Regen.
Sie sass auf dem Dach
und schaute auf uns herunter.
(Richard) Sie sucht den Grenzbereich
in diesen Gebieten.
Ich bin der Meinung,
wenn sich im Leben etwas ereignet,
kann man es sowieso nicht aufhalten.
Für mich ist das Leben
ein geschriebenes Buch,
und man spult das ab.
Wenn es sein soll,
kannst du es nicht aufhalten.
Die Mädchen sind unglaublich.
Sie haben wirklich
gutes Teamwork im Eis gezeigt.
Sie sind wie unter Strom
und hoch motiviert.
Okay.
Juhu!
- Yes.
Lydiane hat ihr morgendliches
Unwohlsein überwunden.
Vielleicht hat das Adrenalin
im Angesicht des Min-Teke-Abenteuers
geholfen.
Ich glaube, wir haben
gute Entscheidungen getroffen.
Das war cool
in der Mitte des Gletschers.
Super,
dass wir diesen Weg gefunden haben.
Der morgige Tag beinhaltet
eine Passage über ein Eisfeld
und einen Bergschrund,
dessen Gefährlichkeit
sie vom ersten high camp aus
nicht abschätzen können.
* Langsame Hornklänge *
Dann lass den Rucksack hier.
Wir reichen ihn dir nachher hoch.
Ja. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Willst du noch mehr Schrauben?
Ach, Shit.
Also, ich gehe hoch
und hole Lisa nach.
Und ihr kommt ...
... und hängt das Seil ein.
- Ja.
Kannst du mich festhalten?
Lisa, du musst sie reinnehmen.
Schauen,
dass ich das nicht kaputt mache.
Allez.
- Yes. - Come on.
Super, Ramona.
Nach der Überwindung
des tückischen Bergschrundes
geht es weiter
über eine rund 100 m hohe Eiswand ―
in zwei Seilschaften,
um schneller voranzukommen.
Lisa kämpft mit sich und dem Berg.
In dieser Höhe setzt ihr
das Leistungsasthma zu,
an dem sie
seit einigen Jahren leidet.
Und auch die andere Seilschaft
erlebt eine unliebsame Überraschung.
Steinschlag.
Traversiert nach rechts!
Super, Lydiane.
Allez, tipptopp.
Der Schreckmoment ist vorbei,
die bedrängte Seilschaft
bringt sich in der Linie
ihrer Kolleginnen in Sicherheit.
* Schwere Atemzüge *
Hey, Lisa.
* Jubelrufe *
Der Pass liegt genau auf der Grenze
zu Tadschikistan.
Was ist jetzt der Plan?
Äh, zelten!
- Wo?
Ist das schon geplant?
- Wahrscheinlich dort hinten.
Da oben?
- Ja.
Wir haben einen Spion
auf der Tadschikistan-Seite.
Wir wollten doch immer schon
nach Tadschikistan.
Jetzt sind wir da.
- Wir sind da.
Wir haben sie verarscht.
Wir haben den Fünfer und das Weggli.
Eigentlich
bräuchten wir ein Visum, nicht?
* Die anderen lachen. *
Keinen Schritt weiter!
(Caro) Okay.
- We did it.
You did it.
- Time to bivouac.
Wir haben den Pass erreicht,
und hier ist der Gipfel.
Er ist nicht so nah,
wie es von hier aus scheint.
Es sind noch 800 Höhenmeter.
* Fröhliche Klaviermelodie *
4.30 Uhr in der Früh.
Nach zwei Tagen Aufstieg will
das SAC-Frauen-Expeditionsteam heute
den Gipfel des Min Teke erreichen.
Rund 800 Höhenmeter
sind zu bewältigen.
Die geplante Route
führt mehrheitlich über blankes Eis.
In zwei Seilschaften machen sich
die jungen Alpinistinnen daran,
die Eiswand zu bezwingen,
und haben dabei ziemlich
unterschiedliche Herangehensweisen.
Anne scheint die Höhe
nichts anzuhaben.
* Eindringliche, sphärische Klänge *
Vor einem Jahr
hat sie die Matura bestanden
und studiert seither
Materialwissenschaften.
Es ist so, dass wir uns in einem
Kletterverein kennengelernt haben.
Vor längerer Zeit.
Wir gingen immer klettern,
und als Anne da war,
musste sie einfach mitkommen.
Wir zogen um und hatten hier
nie einen Babysitter.
Also gab's ein Traggeschirr
und sie kam mit.
Am Anfang war es für uns
auch eher egoistisch.
Wir wollten unsere Hobbys
nicht aufgeben,
darum haben wir auch nicht gefragt.
Sie musste einfach mitkommen.
Ja, vom Temperament her,
würde ich sagen,
ist sie immer eher still gewesen.
Also, still vom Reden her,
aber sehr ...
... viel Bewegungsdrang.
Sie spricht kurz und knapp.
Sie ist eher
der wissenschaftliche Typ.
Sie schreibt mal einen Satz,
das ist die Antwort, fertig.
(Lisa) Anne, ich wäre froh, wenn du
nicht links runterfallen würdest.
(Anne) Ja, es ist nicht schwierig.
- Könntest du nach rechts gehen?
Ja.
* Schweres Atmen *
Lisa und Anne
sind auch in der Schweiz
oft gemeinsam in den Bergen unterwegs
und ein eingespieltes Team.
* Schwere Atemzüge *
Anne, wie hoch sind wir etwa?
5'000.
- Wichtig: atmen nicht vergessen.
Wichtig: Aussicht geniessen.
Wichtig: beide Hände
zum Klettern frei haben.
Ach was, nicht wichtig.
Wichtig ...
... guter Sich... ui!
Sicherungsplatz.
Wichtig: bequemer Sicherungsplatz.
Wie fühlst du dich?
- Gut.
* Langsame, kontrollierte Atemzüge *
Du hast nicht mehr so viel Seil.
(Anne) Also, wenn ich das Seil so
ziehen kann, bist du gut gesichert.
(Lisa) Okay, du hast noch 2 m.
Was? Ja.
- Du kannst noch 2 m ziehen.
Happy Wadenkrampf.
Ich habe keinen Ganzkörperpump,
ich habe einen Ganzbeinpump.
(Anne) Ganzkörperpump
hat man doch nur im Kamin, nicht?
Wir müssen das Seil
noch einmal darüber werfen.
Soll ich gleich weitergehen?
* Schwere Atemzüge *
(Anne) Etwas weiter rechts könntest
du dich ins Eis stellen, aber egal.
* Vereinzelte sphärische Klänge *
Ramona hat den Vorstieg übernommen
und installiert auf dem Eisfeld
im Alleingang ganze vier Seillängen.
* Majestätische, gleitende Musik *
Die letzten Meter vor dem Gipfel.
Ramona steigt vor.
Ihr folgen Anne, dann Flo,
die das nächste Fixseil mitnimmt.
Ich bin hier im Stand.
Dort oben sind die anderen.
Wegen der Sonne sieht man nichts.
Ich bewundere sie dafür,
dass sie das vorsteigen konnte.
Irgendwo da hinter mir
müsste Lydiane kommen.
Lydiane, Caro und Rahel.
Hey, Ramona,
du bist eine verdammte Maschine.
Kurz vor dem Gipfel warten sie
auf die andere Hälfte des Teams.
(Flo) Bravo, bravo.
- Hey, Flo, gratuliere.
Lisa.
- Hey, hey.
Irgendwas.
- Irgendwas, aber bravo.
Elisabeta.
- Elisabeta.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Auch Caro gönnt sich eine kurze Rast,
bevor sie alle gemeinsam die letzten
Meter zum Gipfel zelebrieren.
Min Teke!
Cool.
Der Gipfel des Min Teke,
5'500 m ü.M.
Ein grossartiger Erfolg
für das Frauen-Expeditionsteam.
Die Bergsteigerinnen aus der Schweiz
sind die ersten westlichen Frauen,
die diesen Gipfel je erklommen haben.
* Ruhige, sphärische Klänge *
Nur gerade 10 Min. verbringen
die Alpinistinnen auf dem Gipfel.
Sie wollen das high camp rechtzeitig
vor dem Eindunkeln erreichen.
* Leises Stimmengewirr *
* Verträumte, idyllische Musik *
Morgen früh abseilen.
Nach einer Nacht auf 4'700 m Höhe
geht es morgen ins base camp zurück.
Die Alpinistinnen sind
lange vor Tagesanbruch aufgestanden.
In den Eiswänden,
die heute vor ihnen liegen,
wird die Gefahr von Steinschlag
mit jeder Stunde Sonnenbestrahlung
grösser.
(Ramona) Vier Personen und
zwei Eisschrauben, das hält schon.
* Sie lacht. *
Wie geht's, Flo?
- Tippy-toppy.
Sehr gut sogar.
Hier sieht man überall
Steine im Eis.
In 2 Std. würden wir hier
nicht mehr wirklich sein wollen.
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Die Sonne kommt schon langsam raus.
Ja. Aber bis die Sonne
auf der Wand ist, sind wir weg.
* Eindringlicher Klang *
Das Team sucht nach Alternativen
zum Gletscherabbruch,
durch den sie
beim Aufstieg gekommen sind
und dessen zerklüftete Eismassen
nichts von ihrer Gefährlichkeit
eingebüsst haben.
Sie versucht,
einen Anker mit Klammern zu setzen.
Falls das funktioniert,
gehen wir auch,
sonst kommt sie wieder hoch.
- Can you rappel her again?
Lydiane geht schauen,
ob sie etwas setzen kann.
Wir dachten,
wir nehmen den direkten Weg.
Wir seilen uns zwei- oder dreimal ab
und sind unten auf der Moräne.
Von dort können wir gut gehen.
Das ist besser,
als uns im Gletscher abzuseilen,
dann durchs Mäander
und durch Schnee und Eis zu gehen.
Lydiane bricht das Unterfangen ab.
Es ist zu riskant für eine Gruppe.
Ich geh da nicht
mit neun Leuten rein.
Das hab ich von Anfang an gesagt.
Aber wir mussten es
uns anschauen, nicht?
Der Fels ist nicht fest genug,
und an den Seiten sind wir nicht
vor Steinschlag geschützt.
Wir haben mit Rahel versucht,
ein Seil an der Seite zu befestigen,
aber es wären zu viele Steine
auf dich gefallen.
Und nach den felsigen Stellen
wäre es immer noch weit.
Trotzdem danke.
- Kein Problem, war interessant.
Tut mir leid,
dass es nicht geklappt hat.
Non, merci d'être allé voir.
War einen Versuch wert.
Wohl oder übel müssen sie
die nächstbeste Option nehmen:
den unsicheren Weg
durch den Gletscherabbruch,
dessen Eismassen
ständig in Bewegung sind.
* Helle, klare Klänge *
Der Abbruch ist geschafft.
Das Team hat die Eisschlucht
unbeschadet passiert.
* Helle, klare Klänge *
Nach vier Tagen in Eis und Schnee
kommen sie in ihr Tal zurück.
Insgesamt haben sie
über 1'700 Höhenmeter überwunden.
(Caro) Hey.
- (Silvan) Hey.
How's the hiking?
- Good hike.
Ah ja, good hike, good hike. Hey.
Hallo.
So.
Min Teke ist ein wunderschöner Berg.
Wir dachten schon
als wir ins Tal kamen:
Wow, was für eine Pyramide
aus Eis und Schnee.
Wir haben untereinander diskutiert,
dass er eine super Option wäre,
im Tal neben unserem.
Ich bin sehr glücklich,
dass wir alle zusammen da
hochgegangen sind, als ganzes Team.
Ja, man investiert eigentlich viel.
Z.B., wie wir
zum Min Teke gestartet sind:
Wir haben viel gepackt -
Material und Essen für fünf Tage.
Und du weisst nicht,
ob du hoch kommst.
Wir hätten vielleicht
am ersten Tag schon umdrehen müssen.
Aber man probiert es einfach aus,
und am Ende hat's geklappt.
Ich glaube,
um einen Gipfel zu erreichen,
müssen so viele Dinge stimmen:
Die Gesundheit, das Wetter, das Team
und jedes einzelne Teammitglied.
Ich glaube, da muss man einfach
darauf vertrauen, dass es gut geht
und dass vielleicht etwas
auf uns schaut und uns beschützt.
So ein Ziel zu erreichen
ist schon sehr eindrücklich.
Ausbildungsleiter Silvan freut,
wie die Frauen in den letzten Jahren
zu einem Team zusammengewachsen sind.
Die sechs Frauen haben
über die Jahre team spirit gelernt,
v.a. auch, weil sie oft
zusammen unterwegs waren.
Sie waren auch froh, dass sie
mit anderen Frauen gehen konnten,
statt immer nur mit Kollegen.
Es ist klar, man kann darüber
diskutieren, was besser ist.
Fürs Solo-Bergsteigen
ist es wohl nicht schlecht,
wenn man eine gewisse
soziale Unverträglichkeit hat.
Dann ist einem viel wohler,
wenn man auf irgendeinem Gletscher
allein im Zelt sitzt.
Aber ich denke, das entspricht
auch nicht dem Gefühl des SAC,
der ja eigentlich ein Verein ist,
bei dem es darum geht,
Menschen zusammenzubringen,
die ähnliche Interessen haben.
Aus diesem Grund
sehe ich es eher so,
dass das Ziel sein muss, dass man
den Gipfel gemeinsam erreicht
und zusammenarbeitet, statt dass
jemand im Scheinwerferlicht steht
und die anderen nicht so viel tun.
* Langsame Klänge
eines Streichinstruments *
Während sich Jorra
um das Essen kümmert,
geniesst Ali
die Gesellschaft der Frauen.
Too warm, everything.
Ice? No ice?
No, no: ice.
- Ice.
I here sleep.
- Here sleep? And warm?
Äh ... cold?
- No.
No. Warm. Yes?
* Stimmengewirr *
Von daher wissen wir's nicht.
Gute Appetit.
- (Silvan) Merci.
Gute Appetit!
* Schnelle Klänge
eines Streichinstruments *
Auch nach den Strapazen der Tour
sind die jungen Frauen
noch lange nicht ausgepowert.
Es ist ziemlich lustig,
die Entwicklung zu sehen.
Anfangs waren sie schüchtern.
Sie fragten sich wohl:
"Wer sind diese Frauen,
die 25 Jahre alt
und nicht verheiratet sind
und keine Kinder haben?"
Für sie ist es
ein ziemlich unnatürliches Konzept.
* Schnelle,
orientalisch klingende Musik *
Die meisten Köche sind verheiratet.
Ali hat z.B. fünf Kinder.
Seine Freundin oder seine Frau
hat mit 19 das erste Kind bekommen.
In ihrer Kultur wäre es
auch möglich, zwei Frauen zu haben,
aber sie haben gesagt,
dafür brauche man Geld.
* Orientalisch klingende Musik *
Ich glaube, mit einheimischen Frauen
hätten sie vielleicht
nicht denselben Umgang.
Aber sie respektieren uns
und unsere Kultur.
Ich finde eigentlich sehr schön,
wie sich hier
eine Freundschaft entwickelt.
... on you, okay?
- Me? Oh.
Me no strong.
Come on, Lydiane.
Come on, Lydiane!
- Allez, Lydiane! Almost there.
You strong.
Das Frauen-Expeditionsteam des SAC
plant die letzten Touren
in Kirgistan.
Bergführerin Caro
ist bei der Besprechung nicht dabei.
Für das letzte Abenteuer
tragen die jungen Alpinistinnen
die Verantwortung ganz allein.
Die Bezwingung
des 5'500 m hohen Min Teke
war ein Erfolg für das ganze Team.
Jetzt werden
unterschiedliche Bedürfnisse stärker.
Während die einen in den beein-
druckenden Granithängen hinten im Tal
ihr Glück suchen wollen,
bevorzugen die anderen
eine mixed tour auf einen
der umliegenden Fünftausender.
Das Team will gemeinsam
einige Kilometer weiter
das Tal hoch marschieren.
Dann gehen sie getrennte Wege.
Ramona und Anne
nehmen sich den Pik Three vor,
den sie Franzosengipfel
getauft haben.
Lydiane, Florence und Rahel
wollen über eine Granitwand
zum Pik Aschu aufsteigen.
* Idyllische Musik *
Es sieht wirklich gut aus.
Auch der Fels
auf der rechten Seite der Flanke.
Und da ist auch kein Schnee mehr.
Das sind 250-300 m,
danach kurz über den Grat,
dann bist du auf dem Gipfel.
Ich habe mich entschieden,
in den Fels zu gehen,
obwohl alpin eher mein Stil wäre.
Also mixed.
Also eher Bergsteigen
statt steiles Klettern.
Aber zunächst mal nicht hinschauen
und in den Fels gehen.
Lisa hat ihre Kolleginnen
bis hierher begleitet.
Auf die Teilnahme an einer der beiden
Touren muss sie leider verzichten.
Ich ärgere mich gerade ziemlich.
Von unten hat es für mich länger
und schwieriger ausgesehen,
und jetzt sieht's eigentlich
recht cool aus - beide Optionen.
Der Grat hier
sieht recht interessant aus -
man kann Felsklettern.
Die Wand sieht zwar
megaschwierig aus,
aber es wäre gut, es zu probieren,
weil wir
nicht viel verlieren können.
Wir haben zwei Gipfel geschafft.
Jetzt wäre es cool, mal einzusteigen
und zu sehen, wie weit wir kommen
und was wirklich geht. Aber ich
glaube, bei mir hat das keinen Sinn.
Rahel, Lydiane und Florence
gehen über die Gletschermoräne
weiter zum Pik Aschu.
Bergführerin
Caro und Expeditionsärztin Mirjam
sind mit von der Partie.
Caro möchte sich die Möglichkeit
zum Klettern am Fels
nicht entgehen lassen.
Ramona und Anne beginnen den Aufstieg
zum Pik Three, dem Franzosengipfel.
Eine gemischte
französische Expedition
ist früher im Jahr am Vorgipfel
des Pik Three gescheitert.
Für Alpinistinnen aus dem Westen
wäre es eine Erstbesteigung.
* Antreibende, pulsierende Musik *
Das Team Pik Aschu
nähert sich über die Gletschermoräne
allmählich dem Ende des Tals
und den eindrücklichen Granitwänden,
auf die Rahel, Lydiane
und Florence es abgesehen haben.
Oh, das ist so perfekt!
Du folgst der Risslinie,
die ein bisschen tiefer ist,
und kommst oben rechts raus.
Ich weiss, dass ich
weniger gut klettere als ihr.
Aber ich weiss auch,
dass ihr das unbedingt machen wollt.
Ich bin halt nicht so gut wie ihr.
Aber wärst du bereit,
es zu versuchen?
Und wenn es einfach ist,
machst du den Vorstieg,
und wenn nicht, dann folgst du?
Das habe ich am Min Teke gemacht.
Ich bin nicht vorgestiegen,
weil es nicht mein Terrain war.
Im Moment war ich sicher enttäuscht.
Wenn ich zurückdenke und vergleiche,
ist es die gleiche Situation.
In dieser Wand
ist einfach viel Potenzial.
Wir müssen es uns sicher noch
genauer und von Nahem anschauen.
Und, ja ...
... mal schauen gehen.
Die Optimisten sagen immer:
"Mal schauen."
Die Pessimisten sagen,
dass es nicht möglich ist,
dass man es nicht versuchen sollte.
"Mal schauen" bedeutet,
einen Schritt nach dem anderen
zu nehmen und dann zu entscheiden.
Fertig? Los!
Ursprünglich hat Rahel
eine Verkaufslehre
bei einem
Outdoor-Ausrüster absolviert,
heute trainiert sie die nächste
Generation von Alpinisten.
Ich habe schnell gemerkt, dass ich
nach der Lehre reisen wollen würde.
Dann ging ich nach der Lehre direkt
für vier Monate nach Kanada -
ein wenig Sprachschule
und v.a. reisen.
Nach zwei Wochen kaufte ich mir
Kletterschuhe und einen Gurt.
Am Ende machte ich
einen Klettertrip.
Ich kletterte
die ganzen vier Monate durch.
In der Stube rumzusitzen,
ist nicht unser Ding.
Wann immer es möglich war,
unternahmen wir etwas miteinander.
Weil sie die Jüngste ist, musste sie
nacheifern und war gefordert.
Eins der ersten Male, dass wir
in einem Klettergarten waren ...
Da waren eine Grillstelle
und ein kleiner Klettergarten.
Wir richteten
eine Abseilstelle ein -
vielleicht 3 m über dem Boden.
Sie konnten auf einem Weg
nach oben gehen.
Ich bin nicht sicher,
ob wir sie dann runterliessen
oder ob sie selbst abseilen durften.
Beim ersten Mal reinhängen
gab es ein Riesengeschrei.
Sie hatte natürlich Angst.
Wir sagten einander damals:
"Das wird nichts
mit dem Bergsteigen mit ihr."
Am Fuss des Pik Aschu erreicht
das Team ein erster Funkspruch
von Ramona und Anne
auf der gegenüberliegenden Talseite.
(Ramona) Wo seid ihr?
(Rahel) Äh, am Anfang des Grats.
Und ihr?
(Ramona) Wir gehen zur Wand hoch.
(Rahel) Um für morgen zu schauen?
- Genau.
Habt ihr das base camp
schon aufgestellt?
(Rahel) Mirjam macht's.
Ihr habt beide Kocher
und wir haben keinen.
(Rahel) Ich weiss, darum habe ich
den Funk schon lange an.
Ah, ja. Ja.
Wir haben etwas hastig umgepackt
und alles mitgenommen:
Kochtopf, Gaspatronen,
aber nicht den Kocher.
D.h., wir können
kein Wasser schmelzen,
kein Wasser fürs Essen
oder zum Trinken kochen.
Und ... Ja.
Wir müssen schauen,
was wir daraus machen.
* Ruhige, schwebende Musik *
Bastelwerk.
Wir versuchen,
mit der Sonne Schnee zu schmelzen.
* Ruhige, schwebende Musik *
Rahel, Lydiane und Florence
beginnen am Pik Aschu
mit der Umsetzung ihres Vorhabens.
Sie bringen erste Fixseile
für den morgigen Aufstieg an.
(Rahel) Allez, Lydiane.
Perfetto. Bonito.
* Spannende, eindringliche Musik *
Got to get this ready.
- Yeah.
Yes.
Really good. Stay calm.
You can do it.
Stein!
* Prasseln von Steinen *
I hate that.
Stay there.
Anscheinend ist oben
ein Schneefeld mit Steinen drauf.
Wenn das schmilzt,
kommen die Steine runter.
Am Morgen ist es sicherer,
aber wenn wir hier raufgehen,
müssen wir hier
auch wieder abseilen.
Im Moment scheint das Lydiane
nicht zu stören. Sie geht weiter.
Aber ich finde, das ist nicht
der sicherste Ort in der Wand.
Wir sind hier geschützt,
aber sie bald nicht mehr.
Wir sind heute hier hochgekommen und
haben gleich unser Zelt aufgebaut -
zack, zack, zack,
eins nach dem anderen.
Wir haben eine Line gesehen
und sind gleich eingestiegen.
Diese Line ... Wir haben sie nicht
von Weitem studiert,
sondern
sind einfach reingegangen - bam!
Das mit dem Schneefeld
wussten wir z.B. nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob das zu überstürzt war,
aber wenn wir jetzt nicht Gas geben
und die Fixseile montieren,
läuft uns die Zeit davon.
Es kommt auch darauf an, in welchem
Abstand der Steinschlag ist.
Wenn pro Stunde einige Kiesel
runterkommen, ist es okay.
Aber wenn's alle 5 Min. rattert,
ist das nicht geil.
(Florence)
Wir sind schon eine Weile hier
und es ist
nicht so viel runtergekommen.
Aber wenn man hier schaut ...
(Rahel) It's covered.
- It's covered.
Alles ... alles voller Steinchen.
Im high camp des Teams
Franzosengipfel auf 4'260 m ü.M.
ist die improvisierte
Wasserbeschaffung gelungen,
auch wenn der Kocher
natürlich vermisst wird.
Ich hätte mir beinahe
den Mund verbrannt.
(Ramona) Was gibt's so zu Essen?
Crema Catalana.
Du bist doch
schon fertig, Anne, nicht?
(Anne) Nein.
Ui, hier ist noch Pulver.
Mmh.
Ich habe lange nicht
so etwas Leckeres gegessen.
Seid ihr hochgeklettert?
(Über Funk) Ja, und Lydiane
hat die Seile fixiert,
die ersten 60 m.
Der Fels ist ... ziemlich okay.
Oben war er
etwas schlechter und brüchiger,
aber unten verdammt geil.
Coole Seillänge.
Der Rest oben
sieht etwas steiler aus.
Das Stück ganz oben
haben wir noch nicht gesehen.
Wir haben gerade
warmen Kaffee getrunken und ...
Nein, nein, bei uns ist auch gut.
Wir sind gemütlich vor dem Zelt.
Dann viel Spass morgen und gebt Gas.
* Langsame, sphärische Klänge *
Heute
wollen Ramona und Anne schaffen,
was bisher keinem Frauenteam
aus dem Westen gelungen ist:
der Aufstieg zum gut 5'000 m hohen
Franzosengipfel.
(Ramona) Anne im Vorstieg.
Wir sind auf 4'400 m.
Bald kommt die Sonne raus.
* Schwere Atemzüge *
* Langsame, spannende Musik *
Vom Fuss des Pik Aschu
auf der anderen Seite des Tals aus
beobachten Florence und Mirjam
das Vorankommen der beiden.
In dieser Flanke haben sie
in den Schnee gewechselt,
der an der Sonne liegt.
- Genau, da.
Dann startet auch
das Team Pik Aschu.
Die gestern angebrachten Fixseile
sind wieder abmontiert.
Der ständige Steinschlag
schien ihnen zu gefährlich.
Jetzt haben sie
eine neue Linie gewählt.
Rund 300 Höhenmeter
oder sechs Seillängen
müssen die Alpinistinnen
heute klettern.
(Rahel) Flo in der ersten Seillänge.
* Langsame, spannende Musik *
Das ist eine gute Länge -
nicht zu schwierig für den Start,
auf wunderschönem Granit.
Wenn es flacher ist,
verliert der Fels an Festigkeit,
aber in den steilen Abschnitten
ist er bombastisch.
Nicht immer einfach,
sich zu schützen,
weil die Spalten etwas offen sind,
aber sonst wirklich cool.
Chimney.
And Lydiane climbing.
Rahel an der Line.
* Sphärische Musik *
So nice. This is like ...
Das ist Genussklettern.
(Lydiane) It was a cool chimney.
Der Kamin war grossartig.
Juppie!
- Juhu!
Grand doudou ...
Snow ramp. Mountains.
Warte kurz!
Caro ist die beste Führerin,
die man haben kann.
Sie sagt immer:
"Macht nur, ich folge euch."
Im Moment ist es ihr egal,
ob sie gesichert ist oder nicht.
# You make me feel good,
you make me feel good.
# Oh little sunshine, don't go away.
Yeah, it's coming back!
* Fröhliche, antreibende Musik *
Yes.
Qué bonito.
- Así.
Juhu!
* Jubelrufe *
So good.
Ramona und Anne
sind seit 3 Std. unterwegs.
Schritt für Schritt nähern sie sich
dem Vorgipfel zum Pik Three
auf knapp 4'800 m ü.M.
(Anne) Der Grat war viel länger,
als ich gedacht hatte.
Zum Glück konnten wir
zwischendurch auch laufen,
sonst wären wir ewig dran.
Den ersten Vorgipfel
haben Anne und Ramona erreicht.
Hier musste im Frühjahr eine
französische Expedition umkehren.
Ab jetzt ist die Route wenigstens
für Alpinistinnen aus dem Westen
unbegangenes Terrain.
* Langsame, schwebende Musik *
Und dann stehen sie kurz vor Mittag
auf dem Gipfel des Pik Three.
* Sphärische Musik *
(Mirjam) Juhu! Wir sehen euch
noch nicht, aber wir schauen gleich.
Bist du beim base camp?
Wir sitzen hier
in diesem circle 4'000,
wo die anderen klettern.
Wir gratulieren alle.
Sie freuen sich, euch heute Abend
im base camp zu sehen
und wünschen einen sicheren Abstieg.
Merci.
Und wir gratulieren zusätzlich,
weil ihr das alles
ohne Kocher geschafft habt.
Ja, das war schon hart,
aber wir haben uns durchgeschlagen.
Super, bis später. Tschau.
Es war interessant,
einfach mal richtig weg zu sein.
Man hat sonst auch mal
eine Woche kein Internet,
aber dann hat man wieder WLAN.
Hier ist man richtig weg.
Man muss erst mal drei Tage gehen.
Wenn du ein bisschen krank bist,
ist dir noch stärker bewusst:
"Scheisse, was ist,
wenn sich das nicht bessert?"
Einfach mal richtig von allem Luxus
weg zu sein, den wir so haben.
Ja, man macht schon
viele Erfahrungen,
wenn man in
einer kleinen Gruppe unterwegs ist
und im high camp oben
etwas nicht so läuft, wie's sollte.
Man hat nur
Essen für eine Nacht mitgenommen
und muss eine weitere Nacht bleiben.
Meist ist das gar nicht so tragisch.
Man lernt Zuversicht.
Es funktioniert eigentlich schon.
Es ist auch wichtig,
wie es in der Gruppe läuft.
Man merkt, dass man stark
aufeinander angewiesen ist,
weil sonst keiner da ist. Und
es funktioniert trotzdem megagut.
Am Abend dürfen sich
die kirgisischen Köche
dann auch einmal bedienen lassen -
mit Fondue aus der Schweiz.
* Fröhliche Musik *
* Die Frauen lachen. *
* Sie spricht russisch. *
No?
* Fröhliche Musik *
Hier leben wir komplett im Moment.
Es ist sehr erholsam.
Die Leute zu Hause sagen:
"Du gehst in die Berge,
du studierst - du bist wahnsinnig."
"Du wirst müde sein."
Körperlich ist es vielleicht hart,
aber für den Kopf
ist es unglaublich entspannend,
weil wir im Jetzt leben.
Das sind vier Wochen Expedition.
Man kann sie waschen,
so oft man will,
die Fingernägel bleiben schwarz.
Ich freue mich jetzt richtig darauf,
weiter auf Expedition zu gehen.
Diese erste Erfahrung
war für mich super positiv.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich
in kleineren Gruppen gehen,
aber das hier wird die Tür öffnen
für weitere Expeditionen
in der Zukunft.
Die letzten beiden Jahre
waren wir eigentlich fast nur oder
sehr oft als Team in den Bergen.
Wenn das jetzt plötzlich aufhört,
mache ich plötzlich
nicht mehr so viel.
Das wäre megaschade.
Aber ich glaube schon,
dass es weiterhin
Touren mit unserem Team gibt.
* Idyllische Musik *
Etwas haben die Alpinistinnen
aus der Schweiz noch vor,
bevor sie ihr geliebtes Tal verlassen
und die Heimreise antreten.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Sie lachen. *
* Idyllische Musik *
Nach zwei Tagesmärschen
erreicht das Team wieder Sari-Jaz.
Erschöpft, aber glücklich.
Hello! How are you?
Hello, how are you?
- Good, and you?- Fine.
Caro, Caro, fais la passe!
* Lachen *
Cheers, mate.
- Cheers, mate.
I'll share, I'll share.
Wu-hu! Wu-hu!
Mmh, mmh.
Das ist das beste Sandwich,
das ich je hatte.
(Lisa)
Und niemand wird dir das glauben.
Hunger ist der beste Koch.
Cheers, mate.
Zeit, um Abschied zu nehmen
von den Bergen und Tälern Kirgistans
und den Guides,
die zu Freunden geworden sind.
* Sie sprechen russisch. *
Hey.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Daniel McMinn - 2020